there's been some personal parts of your
life that have been aired somebody was
asking me to
um present the question about I think
it's Adam sosnick is his last name
airing your personal business to the
public when it came to your
I mean yeah do you want to talk about
that a bit yeah I mean I I met Adam and
I met Patrick Beth David they were both
really nice guys they seemed nice to me
I think Adam has made an apology since
he regrets uh saying what he said I'm
not entirely sure why he decided to say
that but uh it is what it is but yeah
it's starting to leak now I think the
world's starting to understand that when
when the feminist the blue-haired angry
feminists say oh this Andrew guy is
lonely and he's going to grow up
childless and all this garbage they're
starting to realize that's simply not
the case it's actually far from it and
um you know T and I have kind of
embarked on
a journey which I would say is the that
the old-fashioned way of doing things
which is to ensure that we have as much
genetic Legacy as as possible and we're
very successful so far I guess that's a
nice polite way of me saying it
um and and that's basically what we're
doing it's actually funny I won't say
his name
because he's a really good friend of
mine and since I've been uh so well
known I've gone to a lot of very
exclusive events and parties and met
some very famous people and I've met a
guy who is exceptionally famous
uh I won't say who it is but this person
and every his household name everybody
would know him
he he has uh he's done something similar
or he's on the same embarking and he
said listen if you get to a certain
level of money and power you realize
that nothing else really matters but
your genetic Legacy and
and he he's taking very elaborate steps
to have children I think he's using
surrogates and he has like 65 children
so far but once once you can once you
can buy but this is all secret right so
nobody No One's Gonna know who I'm
talking about because nobody knows what
he's done but once you can buy children
for money I mean money is not that
important compared to your genetic
Legacy so you get to a point where you
just think oh [ __ ] it well why not I'm
interested have not gone to that extreme
but we have enough money to take care of
a lot of baby mamas let's put it that
way so uh we're doing okay and I and I
try and protect that from the internet I
don't say too much what's going on in my
life because I don't think it's that
relevant and also to protect all parties
involved but Adam shared a bunch of it
and I I accept his apology but yeah it
was certainly inappropriate yeah I
always find it's interesting that that
people try to pry that much into like
because you have somewhat of a public
presence it's like Andrew you have to
show me what your girlfriend what your
whoever looks like like why aren't you
showing me you're like why because yeah
like there's insane people out there
there's a reason why you don't share
certain information publicly like
there's certain parts of a man's life
you want to keep private and it's and
it's advantageous to you in that
relationships or those relationships to
keep it private people just don't seem
to understand they think that just
because you're there that everything has
to become public and they have a right
to a window into your entire life you
were talking to um Piers Morgan about it
during that interview where he was
asking about you know if you were
married and you're like I could or I
couldn't be like why would I reveal that
information can you talk about that just
a little bit more
yeah absolutely because what these
people are doing is
let's put it this way they don't give a
[ __ ] do they they're not interested they
don't want to send us Christmas cards do
they they don't want to [ __ ] they
don't want to send presents on our
birthdays for us and our girlfriends no
no they're looking for attack vectors
things all they want is an attack Vector
they want something they can use against
you there's no other reason they would
possibly give a [ __ ] yeah so it's
foolish to sit there and give it to them
they try and entice out of you with ego
attacks well if you're so smart the word
shows me your girl is she even hot all
this [ __ ] listen that is a that is a
it's a weak attempt to try and Inspire
your ego into making you make a bad
decision but they want attack vectors
they want you to show your weaknesses
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category worry that it
performs best in estrogen metabolism fat
burning your foundational Essentials for
health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out